JONATHAN T
THEN HE'S GOING TO GET TO THE
FRONT OF THE NET.
LINDBLOM ESTABLISHES POSITION.
HE'S CLEAN. PACE THEY EXPECT FR
OSKAR LINDBLOM.
>> Sean: PATRICK BROWN SENT IT
T JUST DIDN'T CAN DUOS BROUGHT
KING SAYS HE EXPECTS THEMELPHIA.
WITH ANOTHER GOOD CHANCE.
THE WAY IT'S GOING.ALIE ALWAYS R
AS WE GET INTO THE FINAL SIX
SECONDS OF THIS SPRAWLINGWHEN T
STARTED TO SKATE AND MOVE THE
PUCK, THEY SAG, NOW THEY GET MO
TIME.
THEY DON'T NEEDAS
BEEN ON THE DRAW.
HAYES.
1:05 FOR THE MAN ADVANTAGE FOR
THE FLYERS YEAR.
THAT DATES BACK TO
DEFENSE.
RISTOLAINEN GIVES AWAY THE BLUE
LINE WAY TOO EASY.
JONES.
THATean: RIGHT OFF THE DRAW, CAM
ATKINSON'S SHOT BLOCKED BY SETH
JONES AND CLEARED OUT
ATKINSON.
AND ATKINSON, WHO WAS
BROWN, WHO'S TRYING TO ESTABLISH
HIMSELF AS ANT
PLAY. UP OVER THE
SHOULD OVER MARTIN JONES.
TWO GOALS IN THAT PERIOD FOR
DYLAN STROME, AND FOR STRONE, A
FROM FRONT FOR BRASSARD.
AND HE SCORED.
>>TOP
THIS.
HE GETS HALF OF O GO TO
COLLEGE AND BECOME A STUDENT.
WOUND UP GOING PREP SCHOOL,
BECAME A COLLEGE  HARMLESS SHOT.
OH, MAYBE LOST IT THROUOUE IN TE
THIRD PERIOD FOR PHILADELPHI
>> Ray: WHEN CALVIN DE HAAN
BLOWS